ever since Humanity discovered that
there are other places outside of Earth
we've thought about leaving it
on this episode of what if we're going
to do just that
but where would we go
is building a ring World in space a
possibility
maybe terraforming Venus is our best
option for a sustainable life
if we were to leave Earth and create
something like a ring world
where would we find the materials to do
so
and if we lived on Venus how different
would it be from Earth
more about that later in this episode
but before we blast off
why would we ever want to leave
[Music]
well in this first scenario Earth would
look a little bit different
that's because we're now one of
Jupiter's 75 moons
how would Jupiter's super strong gravity
affect our lives
what would our Sky look like
and how dangerous would this new version
of Earth be
all those answers in just a little bit
but right now let's talk about just how
big Jupiter is
this gas giant is so massive that it
could hold more than 1300 Earths
to put it in perspective
if Earth was the size of a grape
Jupiter would be the size of a
basketball
currently we have just a single Moon
Jupiter has 75 so yeah Jupiter's a
pretty big deal
and while orbiting it might be a dream
come true for all you photographers
getting the perfect picture for
Instagram is the least of your worries
because every day is a struggle for
survival
being a moon of Jupiter would be pretty
terrible
but why
well for one thing the temperature is
ridiculously cold
but don't just take our word for it we
spoke to astrophysicist Jack lisauer to
tell us more about this scenario if you
took Earth
and put it around Jupiter now
then of course the sun would be much
fainter
there'd be a lot less energy input in
our biosphere from solar radiation
and the atmosphere would quickly cool
off
depending on where you are on the planet
the temperature ranges between minus 145
degrees
to minus 220 degrees
this is because Jupiter is an average of
778 million kilometers from the Sun
that means Jupiter only gets 3.7 percent
of the light that Earth gets so it's
going to be a lot darker in your
neighborhood
and the days could be long ones
compared to the length of a 24-hour day
Jupiter's closest Moon IO
nearly doubles Earth with days that are
about 40 hours long
foreign
how long the days would be on our ring
world
or on Venus
wait let's not leave so fast
we should try to make life circling
Jupiter work
with temperatures like this
we'd need to find a completely new way
to live on Earth
what would be the best option for humans
to survive these treacherous conditions
would it be living in heated domes
wearing super insulated spacesuits
or living Underground
think about that and we'll have the
answer for you soon
for now let's talk about some other
things you'll have to avoid on our new
moon planet
the gravitational pull from Jupiter's
other moons as well as the planet itself
would create extreme tidal forces
so tidal forces of course are greater if
the object that creates the tides is
more massive so Moon creating tides on
the Earth is the Moon is not that
massive so the tides on Earth are very
small but Jupiter creating tights on its
Moon IO is much much more massive these
would generate lots of heat on Earth
but only internally
for example Jupiter's external
temperature averages minus 145 degrees
but its core is as hot as parts of the
Sun
so inside our planet would be pretty
toasty
but that'll be about the only good thing
that comes from moving Earth to Jupiter
in addition to heating the Earth's core
tidal waves would also bring daily
earthquakes tsunamis and volcanic
eruptions to Earth
so for sufficiently strong tidal forces
you can have arbitrarily strong
earthquakes arbitrarily High tsunamis
like kilometer sizes even this is almost
incomprehensible as if trying to avoid
all these hazards isn't enough there's
also the possibility of getting cooked
to death
Jupiter's magnetic field is 10 times
stronger than Earth's meaning that it
emits a million times more radiation
than what we're used to if you're as
close to Jupiter as iOS to Jupiter
the radiation you would experience from
ions trapped in in Jupiter's magnetic
field is an order of magnitude more per
day than the lethal radiation for a
human being
so how can you survive this new
treacherous planet
well having a superheated dome and
special suits would certainly help
but your best bet for surviving would be
to live underground
this is actually not so different from
what's happening on Earth today
in certain corners of the world the rich
Elite are building underground bunkers
to survive a potential apocalypse
their Subterranean safe havens are
designed to withstand impending
disasters like bombs pandemics and maybe
even surviving being a moon of Jupiter
but if you were to live underground
how long do you think you could last
how would your mind handle this new
living environment
and what would you do for food you could
dig down towards the Earth's core and
harness its geothermal energy
that means taking heat from the earth
extracted from hot water and rock
creating Steam
the steam would then rotate a turbine
activating a generator and from this you
can get power
luckily for you producing geothermal
energy may be even easier considering
you're now near Jupiter so the earth's
core is hotter than ever before
okay now that you have power how do you
get drinkable water
since all the water on the planet's
surface would be full of radiation
you're going to have to dig below until
you find a source of water
just remember to be careful as digging
around in your underground bunker could
easily cause flooding or cave-ins
and remember you'll need to purify your
water before you drink it
man you've sure been digging for a while
so you must be hungry
hopefully you stocked up on lots of
canned food before bunkering down here
but even that would only last so long
if an entire Society were living
Underground
we need to figure out a way to feed all
these people
if you wanted to actually have a chance
at surviving you'd have to build
hydroponic Gardens to grow fruits and
vegetables
this would allow you to Garden without
soil people use them today to grow herbs
fruits and veggies all year round they
don't take up as much space since you
can stack them vertically hydroponic
Gardens also grow faster and more
consistently than traditional Gardens
and sure let's bring in some farm
animals as well so you don't have to go
vegan
after all this bunker will be quite
massive and they can provide fertilizer
for the garden
so this all sounds pretty good you've
got your home your food and your water
but living underground will still come
with its challenges
if you happen to stumble upon a cave as
you're digging
you might think it's a good thing but
that may not be the case
living underground there are thousands
of diseases lingering about
one of these diseases comes from ticks
if you get bitten by one of them you
could contract what's known as cave
fever
symptoms involve chills headaches
stomach pain and fever eventually you'll
get better
for a while
but the symptoms will come back again
hopefully you brought your medicine as
the only cure for this is lots of
medication and vaccines
now if you manage to avoid cave fever
there's another thing you could fall
victim to
your mind
without consistent sunlight you won't
get any vitamin D
possibly making you depressed not to
mention irritable
if we've done in train or clocks or
circading clocks this alignment is lost
and this is cows of different diseases
such as cancer
and metabolic diseases such such as
obesity and diabetes
were suddenly moved into the orbit of
Jupiter
Jupiter then Jupiter would no longer
protect Earth from cometary bombardment
as a much much smaller Planet than
Jupiter it's unlikely Earth could absorb
these kinds of impacts
this means Earth including the
underground bunkers you built would be
at risk of getting completely destroyed
or at least being significantly chipped
away at
so it's pretty evident that living here
would be impossible
but what if we didn't have to live here
what other options are there for
Humanity
imagined Humanity lived on a ring with a
radius of 150 million kilometers
encircling the Sun
or what if we managed to terraform Venus
to look like this
if Humanity had to leave Earth
where would be the best place for us to
go
would it be a ring world like this
or living on a terraformed Venus
stick around and we'll find out what the
best option is
but first what is a ring World anyway
[Music]
a ring world would be a massive ring
around the Sun it would have its own
gravity ecosystem and atmosphere
and as opposed to being cramped
underground it would be much bigger than
Earth
three million times bigger to be exact
big enough for trillions of people to
call it home
you would live on the landmass on the
inside of the Ring the outer shell would
protect you and a trillion other people
from the hazards of outer space
but how would you build something like
that
well not so fast first we're going to
look at another potential home Venus
in some ways Venus is quite similar to
Earth
at times it's even referred to as
Earth's sister Planet both planets are
roughly the same size have the same mass
the same gravity and they're both made
of the same material
a central iron core and a rocky mantle
unfortunately the comparisons end there
before we colonize Venus we need to
change a couple of things
the scorching temperatures the
incredibly dense atmosphere and the
toxic fumes would be the first things on
our list
I like to think of Venus as its surface
is just 50 kilometers too low
its surface is kind of like this you can
imagine drilling down 50 kilometers down
on Earth it's also would be a hot hell
hole that's kind of what Venus is like
we'd need to put some serious work into
Venus before we could call this planet
home
but our other option the Ring World
wouldn't be a cakewalk either
if we built a structure this massive
what kind of impact would it have on the
solar system
would it remain the same as it is today
would all other planets get completely
destroyed
and would we even be able to build it
with our current technology
[Music]
we wouldn't be able to just stretch the
Earth and reassemble it into a ring
world
one of our biggest problems would be
finding the material to make this thing
the International Space Station roaming
Earth's lower orbit right now weighs
about 420 tons
something as massive as our ring world
would be no less than a million tons
where would we find all the material
needed to build it
well we could travel to Neptune to find
some of it the Kuiper belt beyond the
orbit of Neptune is a ring of icy bodies
that stretches out for almost 3 billion
kilometers
although a lot of these asteroids are
comprised of ice and water
there will be plenty of regular
asteroids made of Rock
some astronomers believe that the Kuiper
belt has enough material for this
project
but who really knows it's hard to tell
exactly how much material we'd need
since Humanity has never made anything
like this before
to build something like this we may need
to sacrifice all the planets moons and
asteroids in our solar system
we'd just be a lonely ring floating in
space
but hopefully this doesn't happen before
we figure out if Venus is a viable
option for us to live on
what would we need to do to make Venus
habitable
well we know that the two most
significant issues we'd need to solve
would be the atmosphere and the
temperature on the planet
the surface of Venus is a sweltering 462
degrees
hot enough to melt lead
the atmosphere on the surface is also
not very hospitable it's 95 times
thicker than Earth's atmosphere is
there's no way we could survive on a
Surface this hot
one way to tame the heat though might be
with hydrogen bombs
when reacting with the carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere
hydrogen bombs would create graphite and
water
this would fall to the planet's surface
and cover 80 of it with oceans
just don't expect any venous deep water
diving as the planet will only have 10
percent as much water as Earth but with
this water it will cool down the planet
and absorb the Heat
similar to The Ring World we'd need to
do some serious resource mining to make
this work
we'd have to harvest hydrogen from
Jupiter and Saturn and get iron aerosol
from asteroids
if our hydrogen bombs went according to
plan the incredibly dense carbon
dioxide-filled atmosphere of Venus would
be reduced to just three times as heavy
as Earth's okay that's more manageable
in addition the sulfuric acid clouds
that hang over the planet would also be
reduced
okay so the atmosphere is clear
now what about the temperature
before we figure that out let's check
back in with our potential ring world
now that we have our materials how are
we going to build this ring world
okay here's the news it would take
millions of hours of physical labor an
army of robots and possibly hundreds of
generations to see this plan to
completion and even as we're building
our Ring World we'll start to realize
that this structure isn't stable enough
because this Mega structure is so
enormous it would break all known
molecular bonds
we'd have to find a way to make use of
one of the fundamental forces of nature
strong nuclear force
of all forces it's the strongest it
bonds material on the scale of the
atomic nucleus so that nothing can break
apart
maybe we could build it out of one of
the strongest materials known to man
graphene
but this material is incredibly rare and
difficult to produce until we figure out
how to mass produce it every
Interstellar body passing through our
solar system would be a threat to the
ring world
now transforming Venus would also take
its fair share of Science Fiction
technology
in order to cool the extremely hot
planet we'd need to divert the Rays of
the Sun
one way to do this would be with solar
shades
this could be done with a series of
small spaceships or one large lens
solar Shades would either be placed on
the surface of Venus or in its
atmosphere
Not only would they cool down the planet
but they'd also reduce radiation
another issue we'd need to worry about
before we started to live on Venus
[Music]
all right so far so good we have a
suitable atmosphere a proper temperature
and clean air
but there's one more thing we're
forgetting about
the days and nights on Venus last an
incredibly long time
Venus rotates once every 243 Earth days
meaning a single day on Venus is 5 800
hours long
a similar issue would occur on the ring
world
with inhabitants experiencing 24 7
daylight we could solve this with panels
inside the ring not only could they
block the sun to simulate nighttime
but they'd also be able to harvest the
sun's energy
to solve this issue on Venus we could
use massive mirrors that would rotate
and reflect the Sun
sure controlling the sun seems like a
pretty enormous task but we've already
come this far so come on let's just take
it one step further
if we could manage to do all this Venus
would feel just like home except with a
touch more gravity
luckily for the Ring World Colony they
wouldn't have to worry about a different
Gravity from that of Earth
that is if they can get the ring world
to spin at a speed of at least 200
million kilometers per hour I know
that's quite fast but it'd build up
speed over time and once we reached the
desired speed maintaining it wouldn't be
hard in the frictionless environment of
space
this would create a centrifugal force
which in turn would create artificial
gravity equal to what we have on Earth
[Music]
but despite the harsher gravity that
we'd find on Venus it would still be
very habitable
not only that but we might not end up
living on the planet's surface for quite
some time
similar to The Ring World building an
entire new civilization could take
Generations
according to NASA we may end up in
floating cities on top of the atmosphere
these would be safe Living Spaces that
we'd occupy as we slowly learn more
about the planet and terraform it
with sufficiently advanced technology
you could have a cloud city on Venus and
there's opinions differ on whether it's
easier to terraform or it's easier to
have a habitable Colony on Venus as a
cloud city
or on the surface and terraform it
so with all we've learned about Venus it
really wouldn't be a horrible option for
Humanity to colonize
sure the planet would rotate the other
way and you'd get a different view of
the Sun but this is an option Humanity
might consider
scientists even look at Venus as a
backup planet for Earth one day
so this is all speculation but it's fun
to speculate and uh there's nothing
no laws of physics that preclude us from
terraforming planets and terraforming
Venus in particular is just a question
of the will and the technology
now don't worry we haven't forgotten
about our ring world
would this Mega structure be as viable
as Venus
well probably not
that's because this epic Mega structure
we created will likely be incredibly
unstable
a single minor asteroid strike would
cause the Ring World to drift closer to
the Sun
and that's one of the more positive
scenarios
an asteroid strike could also Pierce
through the ring causing it to lose its
atmosphere a single failure inside the
ring could Doom the entire structure as
well as its inhabitants
so if we were to look for a new home
after living on a moon of Jupiter Venus
would be a relatively good option
it would take a lot of work and
resources but if completed properly it
could feel just like Earth
where will we go next time on the show a
human-less world
falling into a pool of snake venom or
maybe just seeing what happens if you
were to eat mold
we'll leave all these stories and more
for another what if